j'ai crié de douleur de toutes sortes de
douleur le ventre exploser par une
porsche centenaire le spectacle-bénéfice
wasquehal fidan sera un grand hommage à
jack one porté entre autres par sa
cousine
je ne dis pas souvent mais c'est du
cepii je sais que sa famille s'est hissé
pour eux aussi
[Musique]
ce cri du coeur enregistré à joliette
sera diffusé gratuitement sur internet
dès le 3 décembre prochain
près de deux mois après la mort de jazz
à juan
je pense qu'on avait envie de déposer
nos émotions quelque part parce qu'on en
a eu tous et on avait envie qu'eux
que évidemment par les attikameks les
communautés autochtones en général
[Musique]
près d'une vingtaine d'artistes
autochtones et non autochtones ont
participé à l'enregistrement de waes
capi dame qui signifie rapprochons-nous
attikameks je pense qu'on a tous
beaucoup pleuré on a fait des liens avec
notre famille les gens qui nous
entourent
donc juste pour ça en valait la peine en
fait je pense qu'il faut simplement pas
lâcher qui martelaient en fait le
gouvernement pour la reconnaissance de
la systémique parce que c'est très
important je veux sa portée la lumière
au monde et porter la parole de mes
ancêtres
en plus de favoriser le dialogue cette
initiative issue entre autres du centre
d'amitié autochtone de lanaudière
servira au financement du fonds oise
capitane on s'est dit on va faire un
fonds dans lesquels on va pouvoir
ramasser des fonds pour créer des
projets pour les autochtones en milieu
urbain que ce soit des projets avec les
enfants les aînés les femmes dans le
territoire du québec pour le grand-père
de jake one et pour sa cuisine
cette campagne de financement est un pas
de plus vers un rapprochement ce qui
t'arrive à ma cousine c'était une
tragédie mais il est quelque chose de
beau qui s'enrichit en sorte de ce puits
que ça fait là ce moment le sait tout se
font la queue blanc qui va être annoncé
ça va être ça va pour nous ça va être
pour qu'on se sente en sécurité avoir
une sécurité culturelle que cesse de
pousser
patel
ici oui c'est depuis mai radio-canada
joly
l'éclat